[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael
rosenbaumoo yeah hey how are you
thanks for listening doing some late
night DJs oh yeah man
really not DJing with y'all
I'm losing my mind I'm losing my mind
but that's cool because these
conversations help me get my mind
together because hopefully yeah good
save we're gonna dive into some stuff
and uh I like when guests open up Sam
Whitworth is here uh he was in
Smallville he's done so much for the
Star Wars Universe he's uh
he's done a lot of stuff he was in the
Mist
did you see the Mist I never saw Frank
darabonts the Mist
really good doesn't matter if you
haven't seen it I've seen it uh so check
that out but uh I want to say thank you
for listening to the podcast if you're
here for Sam Whitworth this is a little
podcast uh we have loyal listeners and
they listen because it's not celebrity
[__] but we really get to the
nitty-gritty we talk about real stuff
and uh I hope you'll enjoy it and you'll
subscribe and tell your friends the um
handles are at inside you podcast on
Instagram Facebook at insideipod on the
Twitter
um the patron family go to patreon.com
inside of you they do wonders for the
for the podcast uh become a top tier uh
Patron I'll send you boxes of stuff
merch and notes and we do YouTube lives
and I give you shout outs and it's just
a big family join uh inside uh
patreon.com inside you and of course the
inside of you online store
great stuff there tons of Smallville
merch autograph check it out and also
the talkville podcast
you should check listen that you can
hear me and Ryan talk about and Tom
Welling talk about Smallville
yes
but uh exciting stuff and um please
write a review it really helps the show
um and uh listen to the sponsors
sometimes when I talk about sponsors
because it's sponsors I care about and
believe in and uh they help uh the show
so if you like a product it only helps
the show and that's about it
um
I'll be in uh
I'll be in Wales I'll be in I'll be in a
lot of places just check out my
Instagram the Michael Rosenbaum and
let's just do it let's just freaking get
into it let's get inside of Sam whitwer
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know we finally have
someone in here no we have someone in
here who
has a great voice
what are you talking about Michael you
do so much voice I'm so jealous of your
career tons of voice I don't do like yes
you do I mean I did The Flash and I've
done some characters but Star Wars
you're in that world there's that but
did you know that that you know when I
was uh
when I was gonna come on Smallville I
educated myself as to who you are and I
remember feeling this this great sense
of like God how do you get into voice
over how do you do that it was lucky I
talked about it last night I had the
whole Justice League over that I
recorded with for years yeah all the
cast members except of course Kevin
Conroy because he passed but we were
doing a celebration for him so the whole
cast came over Andrea Romano is a big
director who was directed since the 70s
I've only worked with her once it's
brilliant yeah she's the sweetest one
when she's done everything she worked
with Kevin Conroy from the first time he
did Batman through the end I mean she
worked with him on hundreds and hundreds
of episodes and uh we had a really nice
night and it was cool but was it a so it
was it was a celebration for Kevin so he
was like social and hanging out yeah it
was just like 10 people I ordered a
bunch of food and we sat around we
watched an old episode uh we watched
Kevin's first episode he ever did and
then we watched a little Justice League
talked and hung out and had some laughs
and talked about Kevin people brought
pictures of Kevin
it was really nice but you know again a
quick Kevin what a voice he had I mean
now I think I I've never met the guy
face to face but I met him on zoom over
the lockdown I think you may have even
been part of this sort of virtual con
and he hung out a little bit longer to
talk with me because it turns out we
went to the same school so I didn't know
that I didn't he went to Julia he was a
Juilliard guy so I didn't know that
about him um yeah but uh wow that guy's
terrific you know I went to see mask the
Phantasm in the theater that movie that
no one went to see in the theater but
now is considered a classic Batman uh
animated film yeah oh it was so good you
loved it I loved it it was on Christmas
day that me and my buddy went to see
mask of the Phantasm who's so cool have
you ever seen that Ryan I think I saw it
in the theater but it was I was a child
who did not quite get it didn't get it
because it was I think I was too young
for like the adult themes of Brian's
younger than we are right yeah
four yeah so he's 11 years younger than
you and 16 years younger than me wow
he's my child and he has more facial
hair than I can ever grow that's right
it's an impressive
yeah Benny's Hispanic half Hispanic
right this is true yeah I'm I'm a
quarter Hispanic so a quarter what else
are you
whole bunch of like European stuff like
Ashkenazi Jews
anything that's in here that means yeah
everything is in Europe and then and
then uh like 25 of my genes says you
know I did the DNA tests and stuff like
that 25 of my genes are from Spain so
but uh you know what's cool about you
know you came in the house and unlike
many who come into my house or like well
I got a lot of toys and stuff do you no
but you do oh yes you have a your place
is filled with memorabilia type of stuff
except you have way more signed stuff
which makes me now go I need to take
advantage of when I bump into people if
you are a fan of someone's and you've
seen them at console the time bring
something if you want to say would you
mind signing my Evil Dead poster look at
that but but their thing is is I think
you have a way of saying that where they
they would just go well yeah whereas I
think I would ask for it be like hey
would you mind no but you have a way
Bruce can you sign it well I always do
like if I'm working with someone I
worked with Bruce you know Tom Holland
and I became friends who directed fright
night uh Jason Patrick from Lost Boys
there's a buddy of mine I played hockey
with Kiefer
um Oliver Hudson's dad is Kurt Russell
he said you want me to get him signed
they're like they're easy in sure so
I'll be like yeah yeah I'm like so I
don't feel too weird sometimes I feel
weird I won't give him the check chase
by the way oh God oh my God don't do it
I'll tell you about it oh no chubby
Chase yeah I heard that oh boy oh no it
was it made me I mean I'm already
imagining what it is he was one of my
heroes and it just wasn't a pleasant
experience I've met him before and it's
just like but he's older and I don't
know I just was expecting like you know
everybody was always said things like
you know he's not that nice he's not
that I'm like no Chevy's great I love
Chevy's Legend I defended him and then
all of a sudden I saw the dark side the
dark side but you know but you know he's
older and he's got some issues so I'm I
don't I don't hold it against him maybe
he was having a bad day right Ryan it's
possible it's possible yeah uh really
quick to steer towards signed
memorabilia because up there you have
the thing poster I don't know if you
have it on camera but he's got the
poster from the movie The Thing yes and
John Carpenter's John Carpenter's The
Thing which is still was one of the most
shockingly great movies oh man and that
poster was done overnight by Drew
strewson that piece of art right there
overnight he did in 24 hours because
they needed it in 24 hours and he had to
come up with a concept do this do that
and execute on it and it's one of the
most brilliant posters it is because
it's so ambiguous but like dark yes well
I've also noticed notice that one hand
is flexed like this
and one hand is reaching for you it's
sort of it sort of suggests that the
thing doesn't know it's the thing at
that moment just like in the movie that
the copies you you get the sense that
the copies of the people are not aware
that their copies until a mouth Springs
out of their chest
that's true so one hand is like a victim
one hand is reaching for you yeah I
never noticed that and I I asked Drew
I'm like why did you do that he's like I
don't know just felt right he didn't
have time to think
yeah well no I've I've known him
personally through Frank terabond Drew
actually did a poster for Being Human uh
as a favor to me and you run that for a
couple years yeah uh yeah I was that
that being him was uh went four years
and Drew this is kind of funny
this is where I I would only say this on
the Michael Rosenbaum podcast but since
we're talking like about you know we say
people say things on this that they just
should never say so I think people just
open up and uh you know whatever so so
here's something that has never been
publicly told
um
sci-fi at the time was trying to do a
bunch of different stuff
Being Human was coming out with our
third season and the material was really
strong I felt like we didn't have as
strong a second season but our third
season was really funny and really
strong and really great
and all of our publicity budget was
siphoned over to a new project they were
doing so there was no publicity no
publicity so I I said to the cast I'm
like guys I can get Drew to do this he
offered to do it for a fraction he says
he says you gotta pay me something
because come on I gotta keep the lights
on but I'll not charge you anything near
what I charge for a poster for to paint
a Being Human poster and he'd already
done a piece of art for me for free that
was being human just for out of the
goodness of his heart I said could you
do a full poster he's like that he's
like you have to understand the
commitment
let me guess he gave you a discount I'm
guessing ten thousand uh it was a little
bit more than ten thousand it was a lot
less than thirty thousand twenty five
thousand it was twenty twenty thousand
the address to cast members to chip in
no no what I did was this I said cast
members if I gave you a bunch of juicers
and posters would you sign them and they
said yes I'm like great I'll sell those
to make the money back and that way we
get we get a publicity piece for our
season three and Drew who usually
charges astronomical prices way way way
higher than that I said true would you
do this and he said
yeah okay I'll do it for that so give me
the sweetheart price
you know and then spent weeks weeks
doing this was it great I loved it loved
it now did you get your money back oh
yes so you sold them at cons yeah and
people bought how many did you have oh I
can't remember I have a few lefts
like 80 bucks each somebody 80 bucks
that's it so you just made copies Yeah
well yeah I made these uh sort of prints
and really high quality prints and the
cast signed all of them and I still sell
these on Etsy and stuff so I have some
left so you're the one who paid all of
it I paid the 20 000 yeah and so have
you made your money back yeah you have
yeah yeah that's ballsy and cool yeah
well I had to come up with something I'm
like where's not publicizing what's so
far our best season did the uh publicist
or publicity Department really like it
and use it yeah they did a little bit
but they were also they didn't use it as
much as I'd like because I think they
were a little embarrassed that the actor
is paying his own money yeah because you
guys aren't doing [__] dude so I
remember going into a meeting with
sci-fi and we presented the poster and
it was gorgeous it was it was
legitimately gorgeous and I remember the
exacts at sci-fi they're like well you
have to understand Sam I just wanna we
wanna open up
the possibility that we use this photo
shoot that we did for season three that
we were really proud of we're really
proud of these photos and I'm like these
photos right here they're like yeah
well I put together that shoot too guys
because I did I organized a photo shoot
because we didn't even have so much as a
photo shoot they really didn't didn't
they didn't do anything so I pointed the
game like you like those photos they're
like yeah and I'm like well I did that
that was something I organized and so
I'm like so this poster you understand
like see these from like and I pulled
over open a few photos for them like see
these photos interesting how they're in
the same position as in the poster this
is reference for the poster guys I put
it together a photo shoot that doubled
as reference to give to Drew so he could
make the poster so they are embarrassed
again
probably not the best move in my place
because that were they they said it with
a smile right yeah by the way I gotta
ask It's A Rosenbaum question I always
think you know my friend John heater
name drop uh Napoleon Dynamite he uh he
always gosh you always want to know like
what things cost or what people get paid
or like I'm like yeah cause I'm
interested it's like cool because I know
people get shined a lot some people you
know work really hard and the networks
you know you figure when you make to a
certain you know status or you get a
show that you're gonna get paid well but
obviously we know that's not always true
always true and I want I I would think
sci-fi probably doesn't pay well well
it's interesting sci-fi had a reputation
uh and an earned reputation here I'm
gonna I'm gonna boost them a little bit
they had a reputation for being really
great about renegotiations past season
three or something like that right where
they started really paying well and they
had a really great reputation for that
we were on the cusp of that but there
was a strange snafu that happened on our
show that caused snafu
we were getting ready to to shoot season
four and five back to back we are going
to be renewed for two seasons not just
one but two seasons because they liked
the numbers I mean that my objection was
guys if you if you keep promoting the
show you can grow the audience even
bigger than what it is because we're
we're delivering I think a really good
show
um and they were busy trying to make
other shows and they actually again I
had some people admit to me like yes
part of uh the large part of your
publicity budget is actually going to
the budget of that show and I'm like
that's great terrific which caused me to
that's what it always is we were just
talking about Tom and I about Smallville
it was such a success but they're like
yeah but all our other shows are bombing
so we need to take the money from
smallville's earnings and give it to
these others which is like frustrating
because the some the the math that was
done was like well you guys found your
audience so now we're going to try to
build other audiences for other shows be
like yes but our audience could be twice
as big if you guys just publicized this
anyway now here's where I'm going to
give them credit
we were gonna everyone was gonna sign
the contracts for two seasons of Being
Human four and five and we're gonna
shoot it non-stop kind of like what you
guys have small but we're gonna shoot 26
episodes yeah and we which we we were 13
episode orders so we were like oh boy
here goes
um and it was a Being Human was only
ever 16 to 18 hour days every day you
know so it was a brutal show to do but
we but as brutal as it was we liked the
story The Maniacs that we were working
for are producers and writers were
hilarious and so if you wanted to be
working for someone you wanted to be
working for them right and if you're
going to be trapped on set for 16 to 18
hours you wanted The Maniacs that we had
for cast and crew everything was just oh
my God I love this I like that all of
that that's important so so you were
exhausted but you know and you be dude
and I played such a moody character so
I'd be sitting there brooding on my
character is just brooding and I'm and
I'm I'm getting into this pretty place
and it's like our you know this one this
day was going to go 19 hours so I'm
sitting there and I'm in a bad mood and
then Sam Huntington comes and farts on
my leg
and I'm like I'm like you know it's not
that he farted on my leg his comedic
timing on the fart and the placement of
the fart did it vibrate on your leg Yeah
I was like I was like I could feel that
it went to my bone my you know that
sounds like my kind of guy and and and
and at that point you're like I can't be
in a bad mood now he just farted my bad
mood away you know I understand that's
how I feel about farts they've they you
can fart bad moods yeah
this show is sponsored by better help
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by home Chef Ryan
finally there's a company out there who
when I'm hungry and I want to make food
I don't have to spend hours in the
kitchen or run of the grocery store to
see if I got something right because I
always mess up and if you're like me
by the end of the day you just want to
not worry about what's for dinner
and that's where home Chef comes in say
goodbye to meal planning recipe and do
stress last minute grocery store runs
let home Chef bring simple delicious
home-cooked meals right to your door
um they've got variety flavor it's easy
uh
it's it's amazing and there's little to
no cleanup with this stuff home chef
makes your nightly routine easier and
more exciting with a wide selection of
delicious meals that arrive at your
doorstep in the form of fresh perfectly
pre-portioned ingredients and easy to
follow recipe card
with 30 unique and flavorful Chef
curated meal options available each week
home Chef ensures your taste buds will
never get bored home Chef will recommend
meals based on your selected preferences
with plenty of menu options to fit any
dietary needs looking to master the art
of cooking check out the classic meal
kit options complete with Chef written
step-by-step instructions don't have
time to cook Ryan have a hot delicious
meal on the table and a snap with quick
Solutions like their 15-minute recipes
microwave meals and oven ready options
that save you time and effort in the
kitchen plus cleanup is a breeze
have specific dietary needs explore carb
and calorie conscious menu items
customize your proteins or swap for
vegetarian friendly options what I love
about this is you're getting great
service it's easy to do I I I've said
this before I'm not putting myself down
but if I can do it anyone do it uh it's
and it's delicious it's just these are
good meals you have a variety of things
and it's just better than spending so
much money on all these apps to deliver
food I'm spending endless amounts of
money on this and you don't need to for
a limited time only go to homechef.com
inside for 75 off your first box again
go to homechef.com inside for 75 off
so so anyway uh we we all felt very
strongly about the show clearly we all
loved it so we were gonna do seasons
four and five
and then in international finance
partner the day before the contracts
were signed fell out of the deal so
suddenly there's a whole chunk of the
show that is not being paid for Mark
Stern the head of sci-fi and this is
where I'm going to give sci-fi serious
credit he jumped to action made
Universal by that chunk of the show but
because they weren't expecting to buy a
chunk of a show like a third of a show
it was sold for fire sale prices so so
they couldn't give you raises they
couldn't give us the raises and they
legitimately couldn't they had a really
good reason not to and then the other
you know right exactly but then the
other part of it is that our budget went
down so what happened was this I
remember Anna Fricke the showrunner she
contacted a lot of us and goes remember
she contacted me and I know she
contacted the other leads and she said
what do you think Sam if we ended it on
season four because we could ask them to
end on our you know and she she knew
that there was a new regime coming for
sci-fi and all kinds of stuff she's like
with our budget going down
we can ask for favors from some of the
department heads but people are going to
be taking pay cuts and you can't ask
people to do that for more than a year
and and she goes so we're going to lose
those people and then eventually if we
get a season five it's going to be a
lesser product we're not going to have
any money to do anything to bring in
Castle you said let's just finish it on
four we we all agreed that we're like if
we're gonna have this show end let's end
end it with the good version of our show
let's end it on our steam because of
this weird thing that happened with this
International partner so we decided and
we we asked sci-fi can we end it on this
season right and they said yes but the
only problem is they didn't tell the
fans so the fans were a little bit more
blindsided but we at least had a whole
season to to end our show and I was very
I think we ended it very very strongly
so sci-fi I gotta give him credit yeah
one they saved the show it would have
just gone away and then two
um they let us end it on our own steam
which when does that ever happen I can
count on like never one hand how many
shows I've heard where people get to go
yeah I've been on many shows get stopped
abruptly um let me ask you this you were
born in Illinois
uh were you the kind of kid that was
like
were you just all over the place and
like creative and and just like you knew
that people knew this kid's gonna be an
Entertainer he's going to be an actor is
it something you wanted to do since you
were a kid where did you grow up in
Indiana Indiana yeah right so you were
probably we were probably in the same
boat I'm guessing because no one knew
what to do with us with me oh there was
that how you feel I was just annoying
and and I I didn't I was just weird and
and I I had a lot of energy and I had no
focus and you know no one was
taking me under their wing and saying
let me it's okay it was it was it was
tough it was very tough for me growing
up but what was it like for you did you
have supported parents were they they
were supportive in some ways but
imprinted
some old school programming that was not
necessarily helpful and I think you're
going to relate to this because I'm
seeing you talk about
I wasn't focused and I was you know you
you even your body language seemed to
suggest like ah it's just like kind of a
mess up you swear on this shirt yeah
yeah I felt like I just didn't have any
purpose right yeah yeah so so I you know
with the lockdown in the global pandemic
I have only now at my age
reassessed whether I was the [__] up
that I always believed I was because
throughout my whole life even you know
until like a couple years ago I'm like
I'm a [__] up I am Airhead I'm that from
[__] up whatever yeah yeah
you are not at all but yeah but no I
would describe myself the same way I'm
like my grades were terrible terrible
you know couldn't focus all that stuff
parents didn't like you parents
but they thought some of the things that
I could do were cool but I was not doing
the one thing you're supposed to you're
supposed to do grades and supposed to go
to school and focus instead I was this
long-haired bearded kid who they bearded
yeah in high school yeah you get a beard
like a senior when some of your genes
are Spanish right put it up yep put it
up it happens man it's thick I had a
thick beard at times sometimes I shaved
it sometimes wow you had hair on your
balls like at 12 didn't you yeah just
thick Spanish hair on the balls right
another half goes another high five so
just just saying
um so
so I was you know I looked like a [__]
up I probably talked like what I was
swearing all the time and I was hanging
out with a bunch of musician people who
all are in a band I'm in a band plumber
love plumber
plumber which is a very respectful
respectable name yeah but dude it's like
no one
no one knew what the hell to do with
these kids and we all assumed we were
all on drugs and stuff like that we were
weirdly enough the most like chilled out
we didn't drink we didn't smoke we
didn't do drugs we were just all we
wanted to do was huddle over a computer
or play D and D or record music play
music out for with our friends stuff
like that and people you know there were
a lot of people that assumed that we
were bad news now funny enough my high
school
many of the teachers saw through it
they're like no these are great kids and
they treated us like that that's
unbelievable just [__] what a rarity
yeah so the parents had me tested for
drugs all the time right but the the
people at school were like I mean they
would say [__] to me like you're gonna
be fine like what do you mean I'm gonna
be fine I'm like flunking out of this
class I've been getting a d they're like
that's not what you're for and I'm like
what are you talking about what you're
here for so so
if you and I
were born in Los Angeles it would have
taken people all of five seconds at an
early age to know what we were supposed
to be doing and they would have sent us
in that direction yeah think about that
think about what you were just I was
already I was doing impressions I was
making people laugh I was just all over
the place you're right you're right
about that I feel like you know if we
were born out here that all that energy
in the channels oh he's this is a kid's
an Entertainer he's an actor that's what
he's supposed to do and they would have
been very clear on that but put us in
Indiana and Illinois
even in the suburb of Chicago where I
was at where John Hughes is from I still
didn't have a sense for it now thank God
my high school had an incredible arts
program and all kinds of activities so I
was applied hardcore to that stuff so
you did a lot of theater in high school
yeah but starting when
um starting when as soon as I got there
freshman year I was talking you had no
acting experience no and I didn't take
it seriously but it was fun and and I
was told you know the traditional wisdom
is well that's all fun and games but
eventually you have to get a real job
doctor lawyer or whatever do you have to
not gonna happen never not with my
grades no way so you know so my whole
life I've had this this sort of
subconscious belief that you know like I
never updated the file of oh you're a
fuck-up and over the the lockdown I was
like well let's break it down
play D D with my friends all the time uh
was huddled over a computer doing weird
technical experiments because you know
the Amiga 500 could do some incredible
things sounds like Weird Science yeah
yeah exactly try to create a girl right
no we didn't quite get that far but but
uh you know was recording music and uh
playing with my band
um you know was acting and uh and also
was playing a lot of video games okay
well yeah that all that doesn't make a
lot of sense he's a [__] up be like wait
a second playing video games I make
video games now D and D well I make d d
books
um the acting thing oh yeah I'm an actor
uh what about the weird technical
computer stuff yeah yeah I do that now
too although I'm under NDA so I can't
say what I do but I do weird bizarre
stuff wow that's kind of Cutting Edge
stuff and uh the music thing oh yeah I
draw a paycheck from that as well so
it's like wow wait a second and I
started during the lockdown I'm like
maybe I was never a [__] up maybe it was
like oh but why weren't your grades good
be like because try concentrating in
class when you discovered at 11 and 12
years old what you're supposed to be
doing for the rest of your life all I
could think about was getting home and
recording that song Or messing around
with the computer I have the same thing
it's like you know back then jerking off
in a sock now right jerk no that was it
it's the same a more expensive thing
more expensive right yeah Armani socks
you know
um no I get it um you know uh I remember
things things like
I I I'm the best armpit farter in the
world and my brother was pretty good too
so I said hey they're auditioning people
for America's funniest videos at the
mall and I made my parents take me out
there and we did Jingle Bells with our
armpits Jesus
this happened I auditioned and we didn't
get it but uh I remember going to St
Louis with my parents to a Cardinals
game a baseball game and I was a Mets
fan I hated the Cardinals and they had
it was Ozzy they were doing an Ozzie
Smith movie about Ozzie Smith the
shortstop for the Cardinals and they
were interviewing people outside they're
like oh this and I go oh I gotta be in
this so I went up and I go hey I'm a big
Aussie Smith fan and I'm like 10 years
old and they go hey so what do you like
about Ozzy and I go oh he's really
smooth and he's and I just was making up
because I wanted to be I still have that
video the VHS tape they made it and I
got in I got in that little thing it was
like three seconds long it's me as a
little wiener and uh you know so these
little things along the way I look back
and just making jokes and I used to I
never was able to go out my friends my
parents made me babysit my brother
so on Saturday nights they'd go out and
get drunk man my mom got drunk my dad
wasn't a big drinker but maybe he did
maybe smoking he was coke yeah maybe it
was coke uh but I remember learning
everything that happened in SNL and
they'd come home and I go well I'm the
church lady this is church chat that's
right and I would do that and I would do
them here yeah that's the ticket me and
my wife Morgan Fairchild and I would do
all the Impressions so I knew that there
was something but I didn't know what it
was you know what you were doing is you
were practicing dude maybe I was in yes
no but no in a very real sense you were
practicing I remember talking to uh I I
this crystallized in my brain when when
this friend of mine you know she was
like I want to be a voice actor but she
was always very irritated when I would
break into some weird voice and I'm like
what's interesting because with my
friends a lot of them are actors they
never get irritated when I break it a
boy they break into something similar
and we're always imitating something or
doing some sort of weird Voice or
something like that and I was like wait
a second people who enjoy doing that
well they're doing it for fun but you
know what they're doing while they're
doing it they're learning how their
voice works right they're they're
learning how to change their voice their
mouth their articulators to create
different types of sounds so you were
practicing dude absolutely I remember
taking a dialects course in college and
we had to go and give uh you know a
reading in different accents different
dialects so first so there was an Irish
accent then there was Scottish and then
there was you know in English and all
these things and we got to one and then
I just I got up there and I go
08 and Sterling you think you can
dissect me with him
it's ambitious aren't you and I started
doing this Anthony Hopkins or whatever
the hell it was and I got a D on it
right he's like he was like I didn't
want you to do Impressions we're doing
but I was always like I need to get
things out I need to get things so I get
it I get it entirely
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
when did you know
that I'm really good
when was it that moment I had a teacher
uh her name was her name is Beth Barber
and she was the you know one of the
drama people at the high school uh and
she she said to me on more than one
occasion she would take me aside and she
goes Hey listen I want I want to talk to
you about something I'm like what you
know I'm attracted to you yeah yeah I
will do oh thank God all of my teachers
were extremely appropriate in terms of
because because I got really close to
them we became like friends
she was no mine was Mrs Boss science
teacher and I wish she got inappropriate
I see she was so hot yeah and she was
like you know I'm like 15 years old and
she's like 23 teaching and I'm like oh
my god dream but I hope she likes guys
with no hair on their balls
like little wieners how do you bring
that up anyway by the way by the way
there was this one that's what you think
as a little kid you're like as a 15 16
year old boy your hormones are going
nuts you're like oh my God oh my God
of an intro that me and Glenn Howerton
did with this producer we were sitting
down before we were trying to get this
movie made right we just never got made
but are you still friends with him yeah
yeah
I went to school with him in
Philadelphia yeah have been close since
we met when we were eight well no I was
18 he was like 20. he was a couple years
older than me but I remember we were
meeting with this producer and I don't
know what we were thinking I mean well
look the script was totally it had a lot
of inappropriate humor so we're like
let's you know we're like let's make an
impression and so this woman sits down
at the table with us and we actually
said the following and we'd had some
conversations on the phone so she was
aware we were
goofy right so she sits down
and I'm trying to think who's who opened
this yeah
it like so ice and I she sits down and
me and Glenn are kind of like looking at
her like like this and I said and we
said and I said
hey
do you like big dick
and then Glenn goes I bought two tiny
ones
and then we were just both like like not
giving us like yeah you wanna have a
threesome with two tiny little dicks
she laughed her ass off I'm like okay
let's get to work and stuff like that
but I was it was like that was our way
of breaking the ice which would not fly
that would fly this was like in 2002.
it's like it's harmless well it's
totally yeah like hey you like big dicks
yeah how about two tiny ones
and again she because she had read the
script she was already on board with
that kind of humor we were like going
nuts you know but I mean obviously
Always Sunny I shot their second pilot I
was their camera operator oh my God so
we were all and they never put you in
the series they did once I was trying to
bang Rob and
it didn't succeed I was trying to I was
trying to they were trying to get men to
come to the party party big it's not
nothing you know as they were like no
gay stuff but you know and my character
was like I get it no gay stuff got it
yeah sure understood I'm gonna bang the
[__] out of you so so yeah that was my
character
um and then funny enough so I'm trying
to bank rob in the Always Sunny well I
have a different relationship with Rob
in his Mythic Quest show
um it's not it's quite the opposite I
wanted to bang him in one show I play
his dad in another show so there you go
you play his dad play his dad so you
have this teacher who's like you got
something all that stuff so she blew my
mind she said to me she said to me she
goes you know you could have a career at
this I'm like and I've like long what
what do you mean
um she's like no no you you have
something you could you could do this
for a living and I was like that doesn't
make any sense because I'm in Chicago
and it's not anything that my parents
could imagine you know right but she
said that several times and then where
my parents came in and they they deserve
some credit is that out of desperation
they ended up embracing
what it is that I do because they were
like well you got to go to college I'm
like
good luck with that my grades suck I
barely graduated and they were like well
then you're going to be auditioning for
the drama uh Department of various
colleges and one was Juilliard one was
Juilliard and that's what I got I mean
out of all the ones you could pick the
hardest one to get into what are the in
brief you don't have to get really into
just like what do you do for an audition
what do you have to do to get into Julia
made it up I learned the audition that I
learned the Shakespeare piece that
morning
what do you mean you learned a
Shakespeare piece that morning you
memorized it there was another there was
do you have that kind of memory where
you could just memorize so fast I think
I used to not anymore I'm an old man now
how no but like how how long is this
thing is it monologue yeah thy light uh
Othello yeah and you did it impromptu
almost I was procrastinating you weren't
nervous and barber helped me work on it
that morning she's like Get Up Get the
Hell over to my office we're gonna work
on this monologue and I learned it right
then and we did it and uh I must have
read it the day before
um how long is it five minutes I can't
remember I don't know okay maybe two
minutes so you good how many people are
you auditioning for
uh Michael Khan was there John sticks
and I think Liz Smith there were some of
the founding members of the school were
there they were in Chicago right but do
you have to before you even audition do
you have to send something in you might
have to put in a application I don't
know how the hell I got the uh I mean
like yeah I think they they auditioned
like oh lots of people
and then there are 20 spots and you went
to New York uh no they they had a they
would go to San Francisco New York and
Chicago to audition and Los Angeles do
you think any chance that you're going
to get in no no no I showed up everyone
was all dressed up and looking great and
I showed up in like a trench coat and
like long hair and looked like
I don't know whatever yeah it's like
whatever and ripped jeans and I was
asleep when they posted the callbacks
it's like on the floor and they're like
posted the callbacks and they're like oh
we're calling back so and so and so and
so and I thought I heard my name and I'm
like what the [__] can I go up I'm like
did you mean like Sam yeah
okay and then I left I just didn't I
didn't take it seriously and when did
you get a call
it was uh went did the Callback and then
it was maybe a week or two later that I
was called into the Student Activities
office at high school and there and it
was Juilliard on the phone waiting for
me to talk now how much does it cost to
go to Juilliard I you know a way too
[__] much how did you do it at that
point my parents again uh with the whole
North Shore Chicago thing could could
pay for it but I I think I gave them a
half off with Juilliard because I got
kicked out after two years so I was
happy why did you get kicked out because
it was a terrible fit it's like not a
good fit were you a drinker no we're
doing drugs none of that none of you
just although everyone in high school
said that I was so that was great the
the rumor is a lot kicked out because of
cocaine use I'm like I didn't do it so
what did you do to get kicked out of
Juilliard well
I liked some things and I didn't like
other things and I could apply myself to
the things that I liked but I couldn't
apply myself to the things that I didn't
like and and the other thing was is that
I hadn't really made a commitment of
being an actor because I just didn't
take it seriously that didn't go over
that well but did you do enough in there
that you learned enough to help you yes
I did I've stolen their stuff
you know shamelessly
um I think some of these uh teachers
would be horrified to learn what I've
used their training for
um but here's the thing you know
Juilliard Glenn and I talk about this to
this day Glenn said not a year ago he
said to me and if this shows you that
the people that went to Juilliard all
share the same trauma he said a year ago
he said can you imagine what how good
the Juilliard School of drama would be
if they were interested in helping young
people and I was like yeah I'd be
incredible School wouldn't it maybe
something else because some of the
teachers were incredible they're like
for example uh there's a teacher named
Ralph Zito uh voice and speech he was
unbelievably great and hard on you at
times when you were messing around but
like just terrific Richard Feldman
another one who could be dick Feldman oh
Dickie Feldman Dicky felds Dickie felt
um you know and uh you know there were
there were various teachers there that
were wonderful uh
Becca guy was really sweet to me and and
also hard on me but then there were
teachers there who hated you well they
hated everyone I weirdly
no one really got on my case but I
watched those sometimes they did and I
watched those teachers really hammer
mercilessly on some of the actors so
much so that like I I worked with Keith
when people cry oh yeah all the time it
was tremendous
I never did because I never took it
seriously I was like whatever man you
guys are all trying to learn how to be
actors I don't know what I want to do
for a living
um and that didn't go over well over
there you know what I mean you have this
you have this innate confidence about
you that
I think that's
I mean that's what's gotten you that
obviously talent but to have such a
confidence is a big part of it huge you
just don't seem like someone who really
gets nervous before an audition who gets
no is it has it changed
do you get nervous now are you
second-guessing yourself are you uh are
you too hard on yourself do you get
anxiety what is it well you know what's
interesting and you're I think because
I've you know watched your podcast and
listen to it a lot so I you've talked
about this type of thing always yeah and
the thing is dude in this career
you better accept that sometimes you're
going to be the Bellow the ball you're
going to be so important you're so
important too you're the leader of the
blah blah whatever and then the next
week you can be nobody I mean maybe not
next week but like you alternate from
being someone to no one so you
eventually gotta go it doesn't it
doesn't [__] matter who cares who
cares who [__] cares I get
uncomfortable when when people oh walk
the red carpet I don't want to I don't
want to do it you know what that's funny
you said that I uh I remember my my
manager and I was never good at this go
I want you to go to the Golden Globes
you need to be seen I go I don't have a
project there I don't want to go
somewhere where I don't belong though a
lot of actors go I go I'm not that guy I
went to one Golden Globes and I just
felt weird took my friend it just I
always feel like nobody knows me who am
I what am I doing here I don't belong so
I don't I never did a lot of that and it
might have hurt me he might have been
right I need to do that but a lot of
people can do that I'm not great at it
here's the thing here's the thing your
manager's totally right he's totally
right but but you're the guy
again there's there was an episode of of
this where I was just I I was so happy
you were talking about this because you
were breaking open what the reality is
not the
your manager at that time if he had
learned that Michael Rosenbaum was going
to say on a podcast like well yeah no no
you're a big deal and you're the lead
and then you're done and get to the back
of the line yeah that's not what you say
if you're trying to sell the idea of
like this guy's a huge actor he's the
next big thing oh he's really important
yeah you never ever show that you know
because that would be like showing
weakness there's vulnerability
vulnerability that's what it is and so
you're encouraged to act like you're
this big important thing
but here's here's my argument by being
honest that's a different thing and that
is really appealing I think to be
completely honest about what this
business is so I have a friend I was
tired of lying on myself for so many
years I just felt like you know I feel
better just this is who I am this is
what I dealt with this is you know hire
me because I'm you think I'm down and
I'm and I'm easy to work with and so
yeah but go ahead yeah but no but that's
the thing man like like there are people
out there who that message is going to
be far more useful to them especially
the message of I think people are
opening up to mental health and all that
stuff and like Hey we're human yeah yeah
you know something uh that that your
okay when I was finally after Juilliard
after I got kicked out I had to make a
decision whether I was going to pursue
acting or not I'm like okay now I
actually have to decide
and I remember writing on AOL Because
the Internet was brand new this is like
2 000 or something like that I wrote on
AOL an actor named uh Bruce Campbell do
you know him uh yeah he's right behind
you yeah
so so I wrote Bruce Campbell Bruce
Campbell wrote back and the question was
how do you decide to be an actor and
and he wrote back some of the most
amazing advice you still have it to this
day no no I don't unfortunately but I
remember what he wrote he wrote well
he's like a couple things one
you make the decision and then you don't
look back I'm like that's interesting so
he's saying make a commitment right but
then he said also he's like you know and
also don't expect
that when you get the job that you're
going to be magically happy take the
tools you have right now make yourself
as happy as you can be and I thought
that was such a realistic human way of
thinking about this stuff yeah you know
it's funny I had a conversation with
Bruce not that long ago we were smoking
grass and riding bikes
and he says well
this is my third Act
and I go what he goes It's the Final Act
in his life because he's you know at
that age he's like this is it I got to
do what I want to do this is my last
chance do what I want to do live on my
terms you know
not I'm not doing this kind of [__]
anymore I'm not doing that this is and
we talked about that and it's like you
know there are three acts and I think
you know I'm I'm in my second act and
it's like you know the third act's
coming up and I want to sort of get a
hold on
you know what I really want I'm spending
so much time trying to figure it out
what it is I really want what do you
want what do you want well that's the
question it's I look it's it's the
question and everybody it's like you
know it it's it's you know some people
get mad at me when I say this but you
know it's the Quest for
I don't want to see happiness I want to
say
fulfillment
content being content being
um
just enjoying what you're doing yeah if
you can
um
just trying to
feel good every day try to feel good
every day and tell the people around me
that I love them can I ask you a
question yeah that that's the the last
part is wonderful I love that but can I
ask you a question do you feel like
do you feel like Smallville
and the success of that
warped
your ability to suss out
what's going to make you happy and what
isn't I don't know I don't you know I
I'm certainly grateful I always look at
it as you know how many people in their
lifetimes even an actor how many actors
are there and what percentage of the
world are actors
right
I might get to be on a hit show
something that's Universal that yeah
that people watch after you could still
go to cons and the fans are still there
and it's like it stands the test of time
no one gets to do that no one so
I always said if that's it and I do a
bunch of other fun things great I think
I just
you know I'm glad Smallville happened I
mean I I was I went through some tough
times where I I don't think I was happy
at all but I think that stems from
childhood I think I just I wasn't
working things out things weren't
getting worked out so I would things
would weigh so heavily on me where I
felt just empty all the time and like
not good enough in an insatiable and uh
and I didn't know why I had these things
and until I started working on myself
until I started understanding the
connections the parallels and going oh
that's why I do that that's what and now
that I understand that I could sort of
assess it and go okay why do you feel
this way right now you feel rejected or
you feel this right and and sort of
figure it out and let it go more than I
used to and
that's I'm finally I finally feel like
I'm sort of growing up I fart and I do
stupid [__] but I I feel like I'm I'm
starting to grow up I'm starting to
enjoy things maybe it's then finally I
got on the right meds I don't know but
and that's true I was just having a
conversation with uh a good buddy of
mine who is a great actor you know him
he was over the house last night
and he's like yeah you know I just
having myself for a couple years I you
know my person I'm with
you know it's just not really it hasn't
been working in like is it your fault
you think it was yes it's my fault and I
don't know I go
and we started talking I go listen for
the last four years getting me out of
bed
wasn't easy my dog was the reason I got
out of bed so because I know that I had
to take care of this pup yeah and I
didn't leave the house a lot my anxiety
was through the roof up and down and
this and that I just I was living a life
that I I couldn't live anymore I really
just I go there's got to be and I I told
him I spent two years the last two years
trying to find the right meds because I
felt like there was just something in my
brain that would not allow me to
um
be motivated or enjoy things or you know
it was just I was depressed I was I all
these and people think you're depressed
when you when you're just you know
you're just constantly I don't want to
do this I don't wanna I wasn't like that
and I could fake it and people would
think you're fine
and I said I really think you should
consider seeing a psychiatrist
and talk to him about these feelings
because he hadn't
and maybe there's some mad
an antidepressant that could change your
life and get give you a boost to help
you now for me I was never on
antidepressants growing up never on any
anti-anxxieties never dealt with it the
funny thing is I did dealt with it and I
didn't know it I didn't know all these
things growing up or all anxieties I was
always in a Perpetual state of anxiety
constantly anxious about everything and
I didn't know that that was anxiety this
was this was depression you're down you
go and entertain people at a party and
laugh and everybody loves you and you go
home and you're sad why
and until I got to talk to a
professional and realized I need a
little help
this this was something that changed my
life and I said I think this could
change yours seek It Out Try It
and I think that's why I started opening
up here on this podcast because I think
being vulnerable being real is I'm not
lying to myself anymore I'm going you
feel this way talk to someone
you've got to talk to someone don't just
let it build and build and why why make
yourself suffer so I don't know if that
was the answer but I just got on a
tangent no no no it's because again it's
a
it's
with what the world has been through
recently sure we all got to be talking
about this stuff and the thing is is I
think it's useful for actors and stuff
to talk about it because everyone thinks
because we're constantly projecting
hey we're not only is everything great
with me but I'm special as hell and it's
just what's your next project
I'm writing this I'm doing this I'm
making this I'm I'm working what about
nothing how about just working on myself
yeah just trying to be happier and yeah
that's the thing it's like it's the
thing that I try to tell people is it's
like listen it's not
it's not what you think and you're
dealing with especially you don't talk
about Mental Health
people in our present profession deal
with kind of astronomical uh amount of
the word no and disappointment sure and
all that stuff and you almost have to
just jettison any for me it's jettising
the expectation that any anything should
happen makes me happy yeah thinking
about you know when they're like what do
you want to do next be like how about
this how about I don't know and I don't
want to know because if I start thinking
about that I'm going to start it's gonna
drive me crazy oh why did I get that and
oh why did that person get that and no
no [__] it you know what I think it is a
lot of times when people say what are
you doing what are you up to you feel
compelled to tell them puff up your
chest that I'm doing this I'm this I'm
I'm what's the word I'm um important
well I'm not not important but um
what is it when you cast somebody their
worth there I am I'm valuable valuable
I'm valuable see all the things that I'm
doing that's right I'm valuable and the
reality is and that's why I asked about
the Warped thing because hitting that
thing that you said no one gets to do
what we've gotten to do right and be the
lead of a series and stuff like that or
you know or series regular however many
times or whatever it is
no one gets to do that
I have found there is a real mental
health risk in that because you will
eventually return to real life and
you're not going to have a publicity
team it's constantly uh you've got a
magazine thing all of a sudden it's gone
you're like if you start buying into and
thankfully I was always skeptical of
that [__] like I don't buy into this
don't think that this is this means
anything so so when when you know you
get back to the back of the line
thankfully I had I had a I would leg up
in terms of making that adjustment
because I'm like well you never totally
bought into that [__] now you're
learning you did a little bit though
because it's bugging you it's bugging
you that you're not getting this or that
someone isn't calling you for that but
it shouldn't yeah because [__] it
because it's because it's not these are
goals that are not necessarily going to
create happiness especially dude series
work man
all you're doing is going to work there
is no personal life so how can you say
that that you know like I was very happy
doing Being Human but I didn't have a
personal life not at all there's no time
you probably got really depressed when
it was over each season right or when it
was over for good well it's you know and
you you make that adjustment so warps
your ability to sort of take these
things in yeah you know um
it's funny
and this I I realized I this happened
from childhood is that I've never felt
worthy I've never felt like I'm when I
was on Smallville when I do shows when I
do movies or whatever I do
I'm always
it's it's weird it's like
man I nailed that I did good and I did
really well I I I'm really good I I ever
and then you're like expecting that
everybody should
notice that
and what a mistake that is or comparing
yourself and so what happens is God I'm
really good they're giving me I got this
award and then you know blah blah but
still nothing's changed I'm not getting
what I thought I would get I'm not
getting the the publicity they're not
making me the priority I've always felt
like I've never been the priority and
that always made me sort of what's the
word it uh resentful I always felt like
[__] or jaded like
I never get any [__] the funny thing
is now that I'm working on myself and
doing this I've got more credit for like
playing Lex Luthor or things than I I
never even I never thought I was
appreciated right on all these projects
from the Studios from anything I always
felt like I was this
the other guy not the lead guy not
important you're yeah we'll get you
something but I was always never
important enough and I never should have
looked at it like that I should have
been like dude look what I'm doing I'm
because it all stems from not being good
enough not getting attention all these
things that I had to work on and and
tell that little inner [__] child
that these are great things and you
should be proud of these things and
nobody owes you anything no and and you
no matter how great you think you are or
want to be it's not what's important
that's right it's just it's just it's a
lie it's a lot of [__] well you know in
the the whole thing of like oh it's
going into the third act that whole
thing yeah and what do you want to do
you know I have no answer to what I want
to do at this point and my reasoning is
I'm like yeah but I've already gotten to
do so many things I want to do so why
don't I just go in not [__] knowing I
don't know what do you want what kind of
role like even my managers they get
frustrated with me and rightfully so
they're like what role what do you want
us to look for for you I'm like
I don't know I I got to do cool [__] and
they're like that's useless to us but
thank you for being you're just kind of
like you're not trying as hard no you're
not going I need to say need this you're
like because ever because you go through
that and then I'll be like you know what
makes me really happy is hanging out
with my dogs because I feel like I have
a son because I'm like I'm like I'm Ryan
and Ryan right like your dog too I know
wait wait I'm not Ryan and hang out with
Ryan
I want to hang out with your dog though
is what I'm saying yeah okay cool it
brings me joy and that Honesty brings me
whatever yeah you know what's funny we
haven't even got into go finish her oh
but it's always gonna say like I have
learned like the the life that makes me
the happiest is far more simple than
what it is that I was reaching for
before thinking that would make you
happy it's the little things holding
your dog yeah I love it I got three of
these guys so and and I live in I've
lived in Los Angeles now longer than I
had the entire time that I'd been
working as an actor because the lockdown
and all that stuff but I mean you know I
was constantly being transplanted to
some other city for you know jobs and
stuff like that I love being home and I
love hanging out with my dogs and that
makes me really really really happy
um I hear you a million percent it's
amazing how things have changed yeah
things change but you start feeling is
important my dog's important my feeding
him feeding her making her happy giving
her the things she needs giving her love
making sure she's healthy look we're
almost like we're running out of time
but I gotta tell you we even talk about
like Battlestar Galacticus the whole
season of season uh eight of Smallville
Davis Bloom uh which we were well
received and you know they offered you a
part in the next season to play and
you're like no the audience it was
doomsday uh no it's for uh uh I was
doomsday in season eight and then they
wanted me to play Zod since season nine
and you're like the audience won't
believe it I'm not doing it yeah
which is ballsy it's it's and by the way
they didn't pay you a lot they kept you
as a recurring no no no you remain
because I've never seen season eight
because I left in seven yeah so now that
we're doing talk film you're gonna see
your whole performance oh Jesus Jesus
well just know that that you were a
major building block in that because no
I well no no because I had to study what
you did to see what's possible on the
show and I was like oh the answer is a
lot the answer is you can do a lot on
the show because you were going for it I
mean I was and I I was just so I was
paying special attention to your role
not also because I knew that I had to do
something different because I'm like I
can't
and if I cover the same ground as
Rosenbaum performance wise
um that's not going to win well it's not
you it's not me right and and and he's
already done it and he won he did it you
know everyone loves that character so
I've got to do something totally
different so I but but watching what you
did uh was a huge thing that convinced
me to do the job because they were
sniffing around me for I don't know why
but they were so it was really a do you
want to do it or do you not want to do
it and watching your performance
convince me no I think I want to do it
because you can look look what he did
look what he did
so thank you yeah and which is a good
thing because that led to Being Human
same casting director and they were like
in in Smallville my character is kind of
a monster who didn't want to be a
monster and being human is a slightly
more comedic version of that a vampire
doesn't want to be a vampire and the
casting return eventually was like I
think I know a guy who does this because
I had a lot of practice on Smallville
but just not the funny person so from
your performance and that you got hey I
didn't know is this true you were
engaged to Allison Mack
oh God see this is the great thing about
about rumors
this is all before all that [__]
happened this was like 14
2014-15 yeah so so you know so let me
take you back to just before Supergirl
um TMZ runs this whole information about
me and and that that you know I was
engaged to her while that Nexium stuff
was happening so I started getting all
these social media engaged to her uh
according to TMZ and so so I started
getting all of this social media
harassment really what do you know what
is Whitmore know what does he know yo
were you part of this is are your
initial some I mean like awful awful
stuff
so I I contacted my publicity people I'm
like this has to be squashed because if
I'm anyone who's hiring people
um
they're not why would they want to deal
with this why would they want to deal
with all of this whether whether you
know and they're like well so you
weren't engaged I'm like I don't know
the chick I worked with her but you
never really knew her no no no no so
here's the deal the fans really liked
our relationship on the show so I was
aware that the fans were like we think
that they're actually dating in real
life and I'm like oh great they're
spreading rumors about that but whatever
okay fine then that that story took on a
life of its own and the fans then
decided oh not only are they dating they
just got engaged and I'm like what they
couldn't be further from the truth which
is such a [__] invasive thing when
people are making [__] people said I've
dated look Michael's dating history and
it's girls I've never heard of yeah
never heard of a lot of them yeah
Candace I was happy about Vampire
Diaries I said I dated this girl Candace
um who is great she's great in that show
we went on two dates or something yeah
we had a great time she was awesome that
was it now you were Avenged you were
engaged to her that's never yeah never
engaged in anybody illegitimate child
let me ask you so but really quick so so
dude I thought I I had my public uh
publicity team write TMZ and essentially
say hi you didn't do your due diligence
this is going to harm Sam's ability to
get work and if you can't provide one
[__] photograph of these two people
in public retract your goddamn story or
we're gonna sue you and TMZ
then suddenly started issuing
retractions and then the little sites
issued retractions and within two weeks
I was hired for Supergirl and I remember
being like guys good thing we did that
because if this story because it was
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and it's not because they would
have believed it they would have been
like as too much
unless we did it or not let's not deal
with the drama yeah did you ever because
it's like Superman Supergirl Alice and
Mac this and that oh his you know what
does Sam know you like how my mind works
get ready for this oh my god did you
ever kiss Alice in off screen no okay
never I just wanna know never never but
by the way
it was a shock it was a shot where you
completely shocked when it all happened
like what the hell [__] I think we were
all just shocked it was crazy crazy time
and you know
um you know look
there's people to say whatever they want
about Allison I knew her has really
sweet she's always good to me she was
always great at her job she was a great
actress and um I I couldn't believe it
so that's all I'll say about that look
you've done so much you're gonna have to
come back on but Battlestar Galactic
because Smallville Being Human Once Upon
a Time Supergirl fourth season as the
main antagonist Riverdale Dexter the
Mist with Frank Darabont you also did a
little Walking Dead playing a a zombie
uh you just voice stuff on the
Mandalorian Star Wars Starkiller and
Force Unleashed game series Darth Maul
uh Palpatine and Clone Wars and Rebels
it's unbelievable how why can't I get
one audition for a damn Star Wars dude
it's so look that was because a friend
of mine uh okay so the Force Unleashed
was a video game project and George
Lucas and the team there decided they're
like you know I don't know how this
happened but at some point someone said
and let's pretend like it was George
right so here goes yeah all right you
know what you should do for video games
it's uh you should uh you should hire
that's him uh guy who looks like the he
doesn't just sound like the part but he
looks like the part and you can we can
use our ilm uh technology to put him in
the game
that'd be interesting and someone
decided that the characters needed to be
played by people who looked and felt
like him in the way that the character
would walk and everything would be
dictated by the actor which was not done
in video games back in 2007. so uh my
buddy says you gotta send me your
headshot and you're real
and then he slipped it into the pile and
I happen to look like how they wanted
the character to look you know they they
this artist created this piece of art
that looked somewhat like me and then
they that's the headshot looked like
what they wanted to look like then I
came in for an audition and that's when
me being a Star Wars nerd helped because
there was a scene we were doing and the
character's supposed to start in the
scene meditating assembling his
lightsaber with the force and he's
meditating and then he comes out of the
meditation and has the scene and I did
the scene different every time but the
meditation I always did it really tense
like you know it was like just balled up
in Fists of Fury and White Knuckles and
and after a while the director's like
you know we've done this scene four
times and you've done it different
but the meditation why are you playing
it so tense the meditation you're so
you're so tense in the meditation and I
said he doesn't know how to meditate the
director's like what he's a Sith he
thinks this is how you do it and you
force the pieces together because it's
the this is my jaw the force belongs to
me so I was like Vader would never have
taught him how to find inner peace he
would have taught him to do the opposite
and when I did that I saw a bunch of
lucasfilm people behind this glass wall
at the studio and they were all starting
to look at me and talk about you know
what's he doing and I was told that was
when I got hired for Force Unleashed
like the moment you geeked out on what
the Sith would have taught is when you
got the role and then because of Force
Unleashed Dave filoni hired me for Clone
Wars which is where my voiceover career
began basically how many episodes of
Clone Wars did you do I can't remember
it was something around 11 or something
but the thing is whenever I was in it it
was a big deal they always made a big
deal about it so it feels like I'm in
the show more than I I was but but
basically it started with this character
called the son of mortis who they were
like you want to do Clone Wars I'm like
yeah sure and they're like it's a really
cool role I'm like I just already said
yes you don't have to say that you know
whatever and then eventually I find out
that you're like no you're playing the
dark side of the force there it says
this dream world and Anakin and Obi-Wan
and Ahsoka are in this dream world and
they meet this character named the Sun
and where the audience is going to it's
going to Dawn on them that this is
actually the voice of the dark side
trying to turn to turn everyone you know
and manipulate events and so I did that
and then after that me and Dave became
friends because we were nerding out we
just kept hiring you and then eventually
he was like Hey so you know you got some
friends in lucasfilm I'm doing my Dave
impression and I got some friends and
like some so you probably know we're
gonna bring Darth Maul back I'm like
yeah I've heard he's like what do you
think about that I'm like I don't know
about that dude I don't know if that's a
good idea he's like okay well we gotta
maybe we got something for you in the
future so thanks for coming in and see
you later well and I didn't make the
account I'm like oh so I'm gonna play a
bounty hunter he's like
uh yeah we haven't been listening to the
conversation okay cool cool see you
later see you later I had no idea so he
calls me a year later and he's like so I
need Darth Maul can you do it and I'm
like
what
give me your best Darth Maul well
so Darth Maul from The Phantom Menace by
was voiced by Peter sarafinowitz and he
was very at last ourselves to the Jedi
at last we will have Revenge so I had to
use that voice as the building block
to create my Darth Maul which has
elements of both but it goes in its own
Direction you see you know and so
um wow um so it had it it had to have
the sense of Peter Sarah finowitz like
that being the younger version of the
character but eventually he the the
voice takes some a voice of its own and
and um
and so Dave and I I'm Juilliard that
helped well right and what's hilarious
is that me and ralphsito my Julia are
voice and speech Guru would make Star
Wars jokes all the time so I would say
empressito it's like yes Mr Whitworth I
am your Emperor now make the vowel
sounds correctly this time you know and
it was that's what we would do so now
you know now I wish I could bump into
him and be like I have learned to use my
voice in a natural ways that's Palpatine
is it possible to learn this power Mr
Whitwell not from a Jedi you know so
that is perfect so good Lord the Star
Wars thing has been really fun the mall
character we have done now what feels
like countless hours of that they don't
pay well huh you know what's hilarious
about that what
they the thing I've learned about
lucasfilm and it's true today as it was
back in the independent when I was in
independent Studio days they're very
loyalty based they're so they don't pay
a lot but they bring you back God
they're like if you ever ask them for a
favor they're just like what can we do
you know oh can I you know can I do some
stuff for my album at Skywalker Ranch
like yeah we'll set it up are you
serious crazy stuff they they treat me
so well and my managers have now
realized that like guys it is
you realize if lucasfilm asks us for
anything just say yes because they're
sweethearts then they and they and they
unlike other people where they say oh
it'll be a great favor if you did this
they don't remember favors in this
business they don't care they're trying
to get you to do something lucasfilm
actually if they say could you do us a
favor they remember that you did that
for them right so so yes no one got
animated series as you know people get
paid scale right right but Lucas home
does this wonderful thing where they're
like oh you know Darth Maul is uh in
this Brisk iced tea commercial I'm like
oh what cool do you think that they're
like oh no no don't worry the license
basically says they have to use who we
say they use they're using you so have
fun making a bunch of money on that you
know I mean they're so there you go make
another 10 20 grand
to that commercial was more than that my
friend that was it probably the most
money I'd ever made for the time that I
put in it was like no time at all and it
was insane so lucasfilm takes care of
people they always take care of me
they're awesome man and I'll tell you
free I'd be a stormtrooper you know
what's funny is I've I've asked I
remember asking a lucasfone producer I'm
like why have you guys hired me every
year for 15 years I mean I've been
underfooted because you're good
constantly well they were sweet and said
that but they said I'm like I'm con
they're like because you stay out of our
way Sam I'm like what do you mean I'm
like I'm constantly bugging you guys
well what's going on with this what's
going on with that who's so-and-so and
he's like yeah you're always asking
about plot points you're never asking
for a job you're always asking what's
happening with you know the mandalorians
what's R2D2 thinking at this point you
know what I mean like they're like your
questions are always nerd based but you
never ever ask us for a job you stay out
of our way so they're like be easy to
work with yeah they they have a very
chill mentality over there
where someone who's pumping himself up
and trying to look what you're talking
about I'm so important they don't like
that no they actually like it it's like
who does what did George Lucas do he's
like you know
he's going in for a rehearsal there not
no no like a he's reading people for Han
Solo and uh he's uh going in and oh
Harrison what are you doing here oh hey
George I'm just trying to build a
trellis here for
uh you know the studio Ah that's great
anyway good to see you Harrison it was
great to see you uh hey you know
Harrison's working on your uh travel
yeah yeah he is he was great in American
Graffiti uh we need a reader for these
and we're short one hand solo uh let's
just have Harrison do you think hey
Harrison you know George do you want to
read uh uh can you do the reader for
this uh yeah [__] it okay
and then he's Han Solo you sound exactly
like Harrison Ford no one does Harrison
there's there's okay there's there's
young Harrison Ford Han Solo I'm captain
of the Millennium Falcon chewier tells
me you're looking for a passage to the
Alderaan system then there's then
there's a grandpa here so no four he
doesn't give a [__] about anything but
you know the thing is is he's actually
kind of a teddy Bearer because he gave
key a big hug because of everything
everywhere all at once a short round is
you're gonna teach me how to do this
it's
you know here's the cool thing about all
the voice stuff that I've been given
over the years is that it you
necessarily have to learn how to use
your voice in different ways and so as a
on-camera actor I now know how to do
that job differently you know which is
fun your way all right this is called
[__] talking with Sam Whitwell these are
my talk to your patrons this is rapid
fire do it you gotta answer quickly this
is um my top tier patrons uh they save
the show the patrons in general say the
show go to inside you.com slash no
patreon.com inside of you join support
the show we need you met K Being Human
was and still is one of my favorite
shows as a cast you guys had chemistry
that is so rare and could you tell and
you could tell that all of you not only
got along off camera but genuinely liked
each other as well I'd love to know if
you had a favorite storyline or least
favorite storyline from the show rapid
fire favorite storyline
um was uh basically all of it except and
I wasn't crazy about season too that
would be like my least favorite
storyline I thought we got too gothy I'm
like no it's being human put him with
people and that's the comedy is my
character is just he's like this
mysterious vampire and this and that and
then he has to deal with being at a
grocery store and weird funny [__] that
sounded like Jeff Goldblum a little bit
really oh dude can you do it no do that
again all right here's my characters so
if I so if you do that and you start
stuttering a little bit well yeah oh
yeah hey work on that it's close all
right yeah all right Angela F what was
the most challenging part of filming
Being Human the long long days getting
my ass kicked day and oh you know some
of those bruises you see on the show
they were real
they didn't have to put bruises on me
because I already had them in the
appropriate spots so Bruce Campbell over
there devnex and Sam you said once you
like science fiction with class so for
you what are the key ingredients to
classify it as much
if it's about something has to be about
something you can't just do a science
fiction story it's gonna be like no no
we're doing what it feels like to be
um you know someone who has been broken
up with oh we're doing a story about how
you find your way in the world we're
doing it's always got to be about oh
we're doing a story about drug addiction
it's got to be about something if you
can do that
uh I mean notice that I'm taking on kind
of a chapter thing it's got to be about
something Michelle I know you're a huge
Star Wars nerd who is your all-time
favorite character and why Luke
Skywalker
do you do like Skywalker Impressions I
don't know that's a tough one that's a
tough one he does the Ada he does
everyone's voices but no one can do is
his Leanne did you read any of the
Archie Comics before appearing in
Riverdale I did not I did not and nor
did I know what I was doing on Riverdale
Joshua D if you could only do one live
action roll between Starkiller from the
Force Unleashed or Deacon Saint John
from days gone which one would you
choose and why son of a [__]
um Deacon basically was a live action
rolly you know they basically shot us in
a mocap stage so that was all on camera
Starkiller the mocap wasn't quite up to
Snuff at that point technologically so
I'd love to go back to Starkiller and
and show what we were doing more because
the performance only came through
partially
so what are you doing now
hilarious no no no no I'm just kidding
no yeah I'm gonna do a little bit you
know what they if you're doing something
plug-in lucasfilm and what's your handle
on Instagram
uh S whitwer one on Instagram okay um
but I'm gonna say this I yesterday they
aired an episode where I got to voice
General kale on Willow and that was fun
[__] you general account played by Pat
roach Pat roach you know who Pat roach
is right no dude see that guy next to
you that dude right there yeah yeah yeah
he Pat roach is like the boss battle in
Indiana Jones about four different times
I think actually one was cut but you
remember uh Temple of Doom the big guy
conveyor belt yeah the big dude who's
punching the house at him Pat roach
remember the Natsu the bald guy who
fights him on the Flying Wing yeah
that's Pat roach remember the guy died
right yeah he's no longer with us
unfortunately but do you remember also
the guy who fought Indy in the Marin
Marion Ravenwood bar when it's on fire
yes boom that's Pat roach
um he's all over the place and they just
make him look different and you just
never recognize him but he's no he's the
damn Nazi who's the bald guy with the
big you know oh come here come here you
know and last thing last thing
one by one quickly do as many
impressions as you can saying the name
and then doing it you did Harrison Ford
all right all right all right here we go
Harrison Ford is here uh talking to you
there's a good friend of mine over here
man that's right it's Morgan Freeman hey
I just want to say that Michael
rosenbaum's podcast gives me great peace
of mind
and then of course this one that you do
which is this guy
any sometimes talks like this but you
actually
worked with them so what the [__] am I
doing this is great thing because the
thing is that you can do your Arnold
Schwarzenegger you know and you can do
it come on do it kill me I'm here do it
now but the thing is is that my friend
Glenn Howerton told me that my
Schwarzenegger became better the more
smug I got that's right yeah it did
let me tell you something about it can
you imagine what it's like to be me six
times Mr Olympia right Lou you're doing
great I mean you're never gonna be quite
the best but you'll be second best and
that's great but also listen to me here
because I just I can't lose I love right
it doesn't so Throw It come on
um crazy the FBI is gonna pay me to
learn how to surf
um
prequel Palpatine
every single Jedi is now an enemy of the
Republic Return of the Jedi uh Palpatine
everything that has changed
according to my design your friends up
there in the sanctuary moon are walking
into a trap as is your level Fleet
um you know what in the morning
this is what I'm working on so it's not
going to be good because it ha it only
works the first thing in the morning but
I'm going to try to do it right now
because in the morning
oh yeah very deep tones which I don't
exactly have but I've learned how to do
in the morning at passable James Earl
Jones
you broke into my house
stole my property murdered my servants
and my pets and as what Grieves me the
most
I'm working on that's pretty good that's
right it's not there yet it's not there
yet but why not show what I'm working on
you know I'm trying to think like
about to fall over every night from
learning to do the voice of James Earl
Jones so anyway I'm trying to get there
trying to get there that's awesome dude
that's awesome I do a bad shatter I do a
bad whole bunch of guys well that was
that was freaking plenty oh that was
amazing this has been an absolute
Georgia fun yeah it just with two dudes
talking just two dudes talking I just
dropped something uh oh there's a part
of Indiana Jones fell off God I've got
to learn Indiana Jones I gotta learn how
to do that I've got to learn how to do
that what do you do what do you do what
do you just sort of well here's the
thing he actually went to high school
probably two miles from my house to
Chicago my house so there's the Chicago
thing that he's got going on so this is
a little bit of a Chicago I got a friend
who's a friend buddy who sort of talks
like this a little bit so he's already
halfway there but the whole thing and
then when he gets excited you know you
open it a little bit you um you know
once you did it you took the staff at a
certain place at a certain nah see I'm
losing it now hold on hold on hold on
three po what is it
not entirely stable I'm glad you're here
to tell us these things sure uh what is
it Chewie take the professor in the back
and plug him into the hyperdrive you
know that whole thing Short Round yeah
that was what he has those those yelling
lines right like you know oh my God I
could listen to this Shorty yeah yeah
you're gonna teach me that all right
this has been an absolute treat thank
you for allowing me to be inside of you
I would love to do this again with you
sometime you have you have so much to
talk about we didn't even get into any
of half of it yeah it was just life it's
lifestyle sometimes you've got to do
life yeah let's talk I was I appreciate
that you have that you know about the
Deep walking because people just stay up
here that's what I always say you gotta
get to the Deep walking because that's
when he really well also he can be
subtle he's like
your son
[__] it it is
that [__] or girlfriend
it took my narcotics
now
I know you know what they are there it
is so tell me before I do damage who
won't walk away from he does look little
things but I don't know well there's
there's an area in the voice that is
that you can really if you key into your
own clown that's right but down here
down here down here
where Liam Nations boys yeah go down
here on your channel this next part is
going to be very difficult right they're
going to take you I'm going to have a
particular set of skills we can do this
all day we love you I love you yeah
thanks man awesome man
[Music]
I liked him you know it's funny because
uh we've talked about having him on the
podcast for a while and I've talked to
him he's like what am I coming on and I
kind of lost touch and I'm like people
have been asking about him and he's a
really great guest he was really fun he
was knowledgeable he has done so much
work he has a good spirit about him and
some great stories and I and I thank you
Sammy thanks for coming on the podcast
man I really enjoyed it
um
and of course just uh hopefully you guys
will stick around and um
listen to every episode And subscribe
subscribe to every episode subscribe
thanks for being here Ryan let's go to
the uh top tier patrons yeah let's just
do it
all right Nancy Delia
Brian H Nico P Robert Peterson W Sophie
M Kristen King and I should see Ross C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy El Jamal F
Janelle B Mike E Eldon Supremo 99 more
Santiago M chadw Leanne Janine or Maya
Maddie Belinda and Dave and but Dave H
correct the castlehoff but not David
Hasselhoff Dave Hasselhoff Dave H Hall
Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and
Liliana a Talia and Betsy D chat L Dan
and big Stevie W Angel amrian and see
Cory Kate of Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Camille asked Joni B Joey M
Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L Jake B
Megan T Angela F male s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric a Shane r m
Andreas n Oracle Karina n Amanda R gen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell Billy s jam
and J Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F
Stone H Stone
Miss s Brian L kdb Aaron R Kendall L
house J Meredith I Charlene C and Cara C
thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart for being patrons and supporting
the podcast some of you've been here for
years and uh you know I always feel bad
I'm like am I giving enough merch uh
when I get my boxes and I try to make a
personalized note and I hope you're
enjoying it all and you stick around and
thank you
um thank you so much for uh being here
and uh you know we don't talk that much
you know usually there's a lot of shows
I guess that really talk in the
beginning about things that happen I
guess if something happened you and I
would talk about it right yeah
but you know nothing major has happened
yeah
so there you have it we love you um uh
from the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California I'm Michael Rosenberg I'm
Ryan Davis I'm also here yes hi guys
okay we love you you do we love you
thank you and um always Ryan what what
do we say uh
uh always no no be good
to yourself take care of yourself take
care be good to yourself that's the one
that's it we'll see you hold on it's my
little too
yeah that too
[Music]